En esta ocasión nos preguntan,
¿cuántos palillos vamos a necesitar para formar la figura 50 de esta secuencia?
Así que vamos a echarle un vistazo a esta secuencia.
En el primer caso, en la primera figura de esta secuencia, que por cierto parece una pequeña casa,
¿cuántos palillos tenemos aquí?
Pues tenemos, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, y 6 palillos,
así que nuestra primera figura que tenemos
aquí o el primer objeto,
va a tener 6 palillos en ella, 6 palillos.
Ahora, ¿cuántos palillos necesitamos en
nuestra segunda figura?
Bueno, nosotros tenemos estos 6 palillos de la primera figura... esta es la primera figura que tenemos aquí...
déjame remarcarla para que quede todo claro... ésta es la primera figura que tenemos a la izquierda,
ésta de aquí y vamos a aumentar esta otra parte,
¿cuántos palillos nuevos vamos a tener que aumentar?
Pues son 1, 2, 3, 4, y 5. Así que ahora tenemos 6 palillos, más otros 5 nuevos palillos,
lo cual suma 6 palillos de la figura original,
más 5 nuevos palillos
que estamos aumentando y esto es igual a 11 palillos.
Ahora, ¿qué pasa en este tercer objeto, en esta tercera figura, de casas pegadas una a la otra?
Pues bien, de estas primeras dos casas, ya sabemos que tenemos 11 palillos, no es así,
es la misma figura que la figura 2,
¿y cuántos más vamos a agregar?
Pues vamos a agregar la misma figura
que agregamos en el objeto 2,
justo ésta que está aquí a la izquierda y vamos a agregar la misma extensión a nuestra casa,
si lo quieres visualizar de esa manera.
Así que nuevos palillos vamos a tener,
1, 2, ,3, 4 y este 5.
Esto lo podemos decir, que cada vez que vamos
abajo en esta secuencia,
o mejor visto de esta manera, cada vez que agregamos un nuevo termino a nuestra secuencia
o un nuevo objeto a nuestra secuencia, vamos a aumentar 5 palillos.
Así que tenemos 11 más 5, 11 palillos de esta parte de aquí más 5 nuevos palillos, lo cual es 16.
Lo mismo para esta nueva figura, tenemos la
misma figura anterior, es decir,
16 palillos de esta parte del dibujo y vamos a dibujarlo con mucho cuidado,
vamos a remarcarlo para que tú me creas que esto es lo que ya teníamos anteriormente,
lo remarcamos con buen pulso y después le vamos a agregar 5 nuevos palillos,
para así obtener la nueva figura.
Por lo tanto tenemos 16 más 5, lo cual es 21.
Entonces, con esta información,
¿cómo podemos encontrar cuantos palillos vamos a tener en la figura 50?
Y bueno, podríamos dibujar aquí las 50 figuras
y después contar todos los palillos, pero
eso suena a que nos va a llevar una eternidad,
así que mejor vamos a fijarnos en el patrón
que estamos encontrando.
A cada paso agregamos 5 palillos o tal vez podemos encontrar la fórmula para la eneava figura,
¿cuántos palillos tendría la eneava figura?
Así que vámonos por partes, aquí en la
primera figura lo puedes ver de la siguiente manera,
tenemos 1 palillo más 5 palillos,
¿estás de acuerdo?
Tenemos este primer palillo, el cual puedes
pensar que siempre estuvo ahí
y después agregamos otros 5 palillos más, así que
éste es el primer término de nuestra secuencia.
En el segundo término de nuestra secuencia,
¿qué es lo que tenemos?
Bueno, pues el segundo término es el término
anterior, lo cual es 6, que por cierto,
lo podemos ver como 1 más 5...
como 1 más 5, más el patrón que son
otros 5 palillos, es decir, más 5.
Muy bien y en nuestro tercer término de nuestra
secuencia, pues tenemos todos estos palillos
que tenemos en nuestra segunda figura,
es decir, 1 más 5 más 5 y a esto le vamos a
agregar otros 5 palillos más, es decir, más 5.
Y por último, en nuestro cuarto término,
¿qué vamos a tener?
Pues vamos a tener los mismos palillos que en el tercero, lo cual es 1 más 5 más 5 más 5 y a esto,
a todos estos, le vamos a agregar otros 5 más, más 5, lo que estamos obteniendo 4 veces 5.
Ahora, ¿qué hacemos con toda esta información?
Porque bueno, date cuenta que si escribimos
la primera figura como 1 más 5,
es para que veas lo siguiente.
Mira, tengo 1 más 1 vez 5, en la segunda
figura, ¡mira! tengo 1 más 2 veces 5,
en la tercera, mira, tengo 1 más 3 veces 5 y
en la cuarta, ¿qué crees?
¡mira! tengo 1 más 4 veces 5.
Así que ya puedes ver el patrón,
si tengo el término "n", entonces voy a
tener 1 más "n" veces 5.
¿Estás de acuerdo?
En el primer término es más un 5,
en el segundo término es más dos 5, en el tercer
término es más tres 5,
en el cuarto término son más cuatro 5.
Así que en el término "n", por ejemplo,
si "n" fuera 10 tendríamos 1 más diez 5.
En el término "n" vamos a tener 1 más "n5",
si lo vemos de una manera un poquito abstracta.
Así que si tenemos, el término 50,
que es justo lo que nos pregunta el problema,
¿qué es lo que pasa en la figura 50?
En el término 50,
¿cuántos palillos vamos a tener?
Pues vamos a tener 1 más 50 veces 5, ¿verdad? 1 más 50 por 5 y en este caso "n" es igual a 50,
lo cual es igual a 50 por 5 es 250 exacto,
más 1 tenemos 251, 251 palillos.
En la figura 50 de esta secuencia vamos a
necesitar 251 palillos para armarla.